Speaker 1: OK, let's talk about the Durham report.
Many of you wrote to me and you said, David,
or you actually? Many of you did not say,
David. Many of you used pejoratives and
anti-Semitic terms for me and but still said,
you won't talk about the Durham report,
which has implicated Hillary Clinton in
stealing and spying and being in Trump's
White House and all these different things.
This story has gotten more and more oxygen and
generated more and more stories. And yet all of
the basis for it is bogus and has been debunked.
So what am I talking about? I'm talking about
a series of headlines based on a court filing
by John Durham, John Durham as special counsel,
doing an investigation into Did anyone spy
on Trump and some other different things.
And headlines exploded a few days ago, saying
Hillary infiltrated the Trump White House.
Wow, that's pretty strong. Hillary infiltrated.
Where did they get that? Well, they said the
Durham filing with the court says Hillary
infiltrated and spied and did all these different
things, except remember my acronym caps critically
analyzed primary sources. If you find the court
filing, you go, Sir, where is the word infiltrate?
Where is even a word that means infiltrate?
And it's not there because it's not in the
report. The headlines using the word infiltrate
were then used for further reporting, so you would
look on Fox and they would go headline infiltrate.
It was all bogus. OK. There was an event in Texas
over the weekend. Matt Madison, Cawthorn, Marjorie
Taylor Greene were there, and they're just making
stuff up out of thin air. In this first clip,
you'll see Marjorie Taylor Greene say that Hillary
also hacked the White House. The Hillary campaign
hacked the White House. Now, of course, understand
that there was no Hillary campaign in Trump White
House at the same time. What I mean by that is
by the time that there was a Trump White House,
there was no Hillary campaign because
the campaign ended months before there
was a Trump White House. It doesn't matter, you
know, explain to them, time doesn't work the way
you will. They don't care. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: So let's hope it goes faster
than the Durham report. That right?
Well, that in theory, yeah. I mean,
can you guys believe that here we are? How many
years later? This is twenty twenty two, and
we're still hearing the truth come out
about how the Hillary Clinton campaign
spied on candidate Donald J. Trump, and
then even further, they hacked into the
White House and spied on the president.
Speaker 1: There is no evidence of that,
and it is not what the Durham Court filing says
Speaker 3: the United States. And then here we're,
you know, it's still coming out. It's shameful.
I mean, honestly, what really should happen is
Hillary Clinton should be in jail now. Of course,
Speaker 1: they believe in due process.
The first thing would be, well, you would
charge Hillary. That would be the first step,
and it's for a jury to decide whether she should
be in jail. It's not up to Marjorie Taylor Greene.
They say that they are all about law and order,
and they call for the imprisonment not only of
people who haven't been found guilty of
people who haven't even been charged,
Speaker 3: and every single person that worked
on her campaign and was involved in spying on
a president of the United States. I don't care
about political parties. I don't care about any
of it. When people will go that far to try to
win and defeat their political opponents. They
belong in jail. And right now, we're in a time
where we're seeing, you know, people abusing
power and going after their political enemies.
Speaker 1: We are seeing that, but we're seeing
it from the Trumpian delusional or delusional
Trumpist wing of the party. She's a member of.
Speaker 3: There are people that did break
laws, and they have been charged for the
riot on January six, but right now, they're
still locked up in jail in the D.C. jail.
Speaker 1: Now they care about
pretrial detention. All of a sudden
Speaker 3: pretrial January six defendants. They
deserve their due process rights. They deserve
to be treated. Innocent until proven guilty.
Speaker 1: It is. It is just unbelievable. They
deserve their due process. Rights in prison.
Hillary, despite no indictment, charges trial
or a guilty verdict. But the rioters aren't
being treated properly now. Of course, we've been
talking about the issue of pretrial detention
for years. These people never cared about it.
And there's actually work to be done. We're on
the precipice of a war between Russia and Ukraine
that will throw energy supply chains and the stock
market into chaos and rattle the American economy,
cause inflation, caused chaos, and they've
spent days talking about a Hillary story
based on a distorted report. Which did
not summarize what was actually in the
Durham filing on the basis of which dozens
of stories and hours of reporting were based.
And they say that we're the ones
who aren't talking about the real
issues. Here's one other clip from this same
very strange event in Texas here. Marjorie
Taylor Greene tells the lie that Ukraine was the
top donor to Hillary Clinton's campaign. It's just
it's pulled out of thin air. It's not true.
Speaker 3: I use them all the media would rather
tell you lies about people like us. Call us. All
kinds of horrible names present some character
of us. That is not even true so that people will
think bad things about us, but they don't want to
tell the truth. So many stories like the truth
about what's actually happening in our country.
But yet they'd rather talk about Russia, Russia,
Russia and Ukraine and talk about possible war
than talk about the real truth.
Speaker 1: That's a real story,
Marge, that the Russia Ukraine story
is something that's actually happening.
There is nothing about Hillary infiltrating
the Trump White House. It's just there's
no factual basis for that that Ukraine.
Speaker 3: Don't forget this Ukraine was
the number one donor to Hillary Clinton. No.
Speaker 1: No, Ukraine was not the number one
donor to Hillary Clinton. I don't
even really know what that means
until these people are sued and actually lose a
defamation suit. They will not stop. One thing
that has dramatically reduced the number of these
Hillary stories on Fox and among some other and
right with some other right wing media outlets,
is that at a speech in New York over the weekend,
Hillary Clinton said what is being said about
her is approaching actual malice. Now that is
a legal term relevant to defamation. Remember
that in the case where Sarah Palin sued the New
York Times for defamation last week, a judge
determined there was no proof of actual malice
and malice. Actual malice is very hard to
proof under under, you know, admittedly,
Hillary Clinton saying what they're doing
is approaching actual malice seems to have
made some of these right wing media people
realize we may be going a little too far here,
particularly because all of our apoplectic
headlines about Hillary and spying and
infiltrating are based on bogus interpretations
of the Durham court filing. So it's it's not
going to stop until somebody loses a
defamation suit that you can be sure of